[Music]
on today's show we talked to an
exhausted single mom who's been telling
herself stories about what she can and
can't accomplish
and i teach her how she can take control
of those negative thoughts
we also talk to a young woman whose
parents won't discuss
a will stay tuned
[Music]
hey what's up what's up this is john
with the dr john deloney's show
so glad you're joining us song of the
song it's a show i wish it was a song
about mental health and families
it's a show about mental health and
families we need to write a theme song
like a 90s sitcom which is
you know that just shows your face like
freeze frame with the song underneath it
we have like some cool keyboards like
one of those keyboard guitars that'd be
incredible
oh that would be so good hey so for
inside baseball this is the second time
we are shooting the intro to the show we
had it perfect
we had nailed it we had some cool inside
jokes the banter was great
and um
the video thing crashed and so now we're
just
starting the whole thing over trying to
act all improv like hey what's up
everybody but we're doing it again
we're glad you're back with us even
though you were always just with us and
we're going to talk about relationships
marriage whatever you got going on your
life your jobs your life
everything um and hey we got a new
segment on the show and by the way
welcome back thank you you were gone for
what months
four days four four days
feels like a month you were with middle
school kids like in the woods huh that
sounds
way worse let's just backtrack that
thing
you were on camp and uh
with middle schoolers in the woods yeah
it was elementary school kids
third third through fifth grade boys so
you came back
so basically the maturity level between
what you've been doing
and this show is just about flat there
are actually less poop jokes with the
kids than there are in this show
well you need to hang out with cooler
kids and
because we all deserve a break now and
then kelly's gone today i don't even
know where she's at but madison is here
thanks for sitting in
of course happy to be here you look
great you feel great smart
feel great but i'm here i'm operating
don't that sound under the weather to
you
a little bit yeah you sound over the
weather over the weather you got
covered 16 17 18. all of them all of the
covers not the one nine though
no not the one nine i'm in the clear
hey kelly is doing cpr training right
now with like the dummies that
like you practice on like on the office
when dwight cut the face off
so next time next time she's on the show
you need to just pretend
to be choking or have a heart attack and
just see what she does there's a 100
chance i'm doing that a
they will probably edit this out of the
show they won't let us do it on the show
but we're gonna have video of that and b
what's that
what's that song that they sing stay in
alignment stay in alive
that's going to be the song of the day
the next time that'd be so great
and see if she even catches it um for
those of y'all who are regulars you all
know that kelly's not always the
sharpest tool in the shed but she may
get this one she may get this one
actually kelly's way smarter than all of
us um hey we have a new segment on the
show
not we used to do like back in the day
we did um the most annoying thing we got
a new segment called
i'm cool with that so the first and
maybe
only um entry into i'm cool with that
was today on the way to work i saw a guy
driving next to me
in a truck that he had painted camo
and i was just thinking man that dude's
got
hundreds of dollars of sitka gear he
sprays himself down in deer urine
and all the stuff so that he can hide
from these
poor little whitetails and the rabbits
and whatever but then he thinks
you know what they won't see my f-250
because i spray-painted it black and
brown and green no one's gonna see it
but you know what i'm cool with that and
if you're driving down the highway in a
camo truck right now
high five to you brother i don't know i
don't
at some point you thought you know what
this is gonna be a good idea and so i'm
gonna high five you on that one i
support you
go camo truck people if you wanna have a
camo car
if somebody'll have a camo prius and
just send me a photo of it um
everything that i ever do for the rest
of my career i'll give to you for free
um tickets books everything you just get
for free if you have a prius that is
painted camo
you win life you've won everything um if
you pull up to a
eating establishment or a bar or
something in a camo painted prius
everyone just leaves who they're with
and they go home with you it's
incredible
all right um let's do this let's go how
about some calls about that let's go to
cara in sacramento cara
it is super early good morning good
morning
has the world even started where you are
um it has for me
well played i see what you did there
that was awesome so how in the world are
you
i'm great thank you i'm so honored that
you
invited me to the show today oh you're
so i'm i'm honored
um this is not a uh this isn't the upper
echelon of shows
and so i'm so glad that you're with us
um okay so for
the listeners um maybe a week ago two
weeks ago
i was co-hosting dave ramsey show
and you called in and uh we had a lovely
conversation
and then i thought you know what i want
to dig in and
share your conversation with the folks
who listen to our show and i also want
to hear how the last week has been
so let's let's hit rewind and
slap it up flip it reverse it and you
can tell us why'd you call dave's show
and tell us what's going on in your
world
um i called because um i'm grateful i'm
so thankful for my co-worker who
introduced me to
dave ramsey and and since i found
all the personalities and i've been
obsessing and listening to podcasts and
watching on youtube
and um so when i called you um
you were the co-host and i was the um
the title was overwhelmed single mom
which is
exactly what i am and um
and you guys made me feel so much better
i am on the back end i'm almost done
i think like he said i had battle
fatigue and um
you know i just i was doing the every
dollar app and
every time i'm over budget even without
putting
miscellaneous fun money giving any of
that just the basics and my rent's going
up next month or in august so
so that's why i was just at my breaking
point that day and um
you guys really made me feel better and
then we talked about going to school
and you said i need to get the
roadblocks out of my own mind
um to be able to do that and i've
actually attempted to go back to school
a couple of times
um well actually i've taken classes here
and there and then my
um i was working full-time in in school
full-time going to do a
lvn program at bridge to rn and then
um my ex-husband took me to court for
um 50 custody he said i was an absent
parent
so then i obviously i stopped at that
point
now that she's older i'm just getting
ready to start um
so that's that's where we are and i
think that's why i have roadblocks
because it's like
something's always kind of came up you
know yeah you've got an
idiot in your life that's decidedly he's
it
i'm gonna make things complicated he is
so much better now
i have to say i'm i'm so grateful for
his girlfriend now who's now his fiance
and i even told him he better not mess
this up
hey he's amazing you are person of the
century
so you how long ago did you get divorced
um 2008 2008 okay and
i'm assuming it didn't end super great
like you weren't thrilled about this
okay no in 2016 is when i was going back
to school
and he took me to court and all that
good stuff
um that was a few years ago and then
since
then he's um started dating this girl
who had actually been a friend of his
for a long time and
my girls when they go over there they go
places together like
you know six flags all that kind of
stuff and you know they eventually got
together and i was like thank god
because i know
um when they're there i don't have to
worry they're being well taken care of
and she loves them just as much as she
loves her boys and
i'm i'm very grateful for her so for
every
wow so for every husband
ex-husband ex-wife listening to this
every soon-to-be we've got people who've
just been filed on recently or who have
been separated for a while and are
waiting to go ahead and make those final
moves
how in the world did you get yourself in
a place where somebody hurt you real bad
and you had a life track you had little
kids you're married and all of a sudden
your life takes a left turn
and you must have found some sort of
resilience and strength
and i mean power that very few
will ever have to come to a place where
you're cheering him on for his new
girlfriend and you're so grateful that
your daughters are
how did you make that shift um
maturity growing up um oh stop it with
your maturity care
come on no i'm still kidding no it's
good for you
it's about the kids and it was hard
don't i mean it was no picnic i mean it
just took time and um
you know and the kids were so much
happier when we got along and there was
a lot of me biting my tongue
and it still kind of happens from time
to time i just like you know
this is your dad and you know just
like she wanted to play sports and then
they were doing covid
testing every two weeks not making them
get the shot and he was like
no i don't want you getting tested i
want your dna and assistant i'm like
what is he even talking about
like if they wanted their dna they could
find it and we're not that important fyi
you know but you know so i said well
here i said why don't you write a list
of
10 reasons why you want to do it and
that would probably
see him make him realize what you want
to do it's going to be your senior year
blah blah blah
she didn't do it but she's going to do
it for a senior year because like her
junior years when that was happening i'm
like
you know so there's still times i have
to bite my tongue and i said well i'll
say some
no mom don't say something because i
said i'm not afraid to say something
your dash because i know that's why i
didn't tell you at first but
okay but but so the key here is this is
a process right and then
at the end of the day you made a choice
it's more important that i love how you
say that it's important that we get
along it's better for me it's better for
him it's better for our kids most
importantly
and i'm not gonna pick fights i'm not
even gonna finish fights
i'm gonna check in with my soon-to-be
adult daughter
but it's a it's a daily commitment to oh
i'm gonna bite my tongue on this one
i'm going to talk with my daughter on
this one hey i'm going to sit down with
him and have a conversation good for you
everybody listening the two words there
intentionality
and process right people think oh i'm
just going to be all better now that's
not how it works man
10 years later you're still struggling
with this and every day so you got to
wake up and make a decision right
so back um back to that phone call you
called and
you like millions of single moms
like single men and women like married
men and women
you looked at your budget and the
numbers didn't add up
and you're working hard you're exhausted
um you're trying to do the best you can
for the people around you you count on
you
but it didn't add up and that nagging
question is
i can't go back to school i can't do
this stuff i'm too old for this
what about that walk me through that
um well my stories you're telling
yourself those negative stories
tell me about those negative stories
you're telling yourself oh i've got
plenty of those
okay so um a lot of it is like
i want to be able to take trips
with and make memories with my kids
while they're still home now
i feel like i'm out of time almost
because she's going to be a senior this
year i'm not completely out of time but
um you know that's my biggest thing is
be able to make memories and
do things like it's not about stuff it's
about memories and
i guess now i'll be able to do that as
their adult which
i have to get over the regret of missing
so much when they were kids because i
was just
working myself to death and then um i'm
i'm getting to where i'm like okay i
need to start saving for retirement
but you know because i'm terrified the
older i get like
you know and as dave pointed out i'm not
that old but
but i'm you know i'm 44 so i'm like okay
i don't want to keep working until i'm
like
80 and i've never i've never owned a
home i want to buy a home in california
that's
really pretty much impossible on one
income unless
um you have a higher paying job which i
want to do i want to go back to school
i've always wanted to do that
and so it's just i'm kind of battling
these things in my head like
prioritizing
the memories with the kids but the 401
or 403b is the medical one um it's like
a 401k
i'll do that eventually i feel like
that's not a priority
it's more of and then i'm like i don't
really need a big house now but i do
want to own so i don't have to worry
about the rent keep going up like it is
again this month
so i want to give you two secret
tricks okay okay and by secret i mean
i'm writing a book on it so it's not
secret at all okay oh
um i'm working on it and this will be
you'll you'll get this about
seven months before the rest of the
world gets it okay okay
so there's a two things i want you to to
do if you have a close friend
that you trust i'd love you to do this
with them
um in their presence okay because some
of these things can get heavy
and some of them um take a another set
of eyes if you don't
then you may want to get a counselor and
say hey this knucklehead idiot on the
radio on a podcast on the radio
asked me to do this thing and i want you
to walk through it with me and if the
counselor says
well let's do an assessment and just say
okay then you don't want my money i'm
gonna go somewhere else but you'll find
somebody that will walk alongside this
with you
okay okay so you
man it's almost like you're meaning the
budget or like the map no no no no
so in the same way you do a budget in
the same way you sit down and say
what are my expenses what do um how much
money do i make and how do i allocate
this
sometimes you realize i got to get a new
job sometimes you realize i gotta cut
expenses sometimes you realize i
get a second or third job in this one
season so that i can
xyz right yes and i've been working
a lot of extra shifts and taking an
extra call oh yeah
yeah yeah no you're working yourself
yeah you have very little muscle and
skin left you're down to bone right
you're cutting into
bone right yeah pretty much so here's
what i want you to do
in just asking you a couple of stories
you mentioned
i'm out of time you mentioned regret
you mentioned surviving you mentioned
things that you
want or i'll even say wanted like a
house
like this like a vet all of those
stories you
that you're telling yourself they're all
true and they're all real
those things have become bricks in your
backpack that you carry around
right and they abs every morning you
wake up
and you stand up tall and you try to
stretch and your shoulders are hunched
over
and you begin thinking i just gotta go
do this
and i gotta do that and i sure would
love to have this i don't even have that
and oh my gosh i gotta go
and your day starts right with you just
completely weighed down so i want you to
take a piece of paper
and i am a big proponent of
getting like a 99 cent uh yellow pad
and a pen write this down don't use a
computer
and i want you to write down the stories
you tell yourself
especially ones that include regrets
things i should haves i must haves can't
believe i didn't
i'm pissed off that right the things
about regret the things about i'm just
trying to survive
and then i want you to go through those
things and i want you to demand evidence
whether they're true or not
okay okay so sometimes you can draw a
line on a piece of paper or sometimes
out to the margin you can just write not
true
so for instance i cannot go back to
school right now
that's a story you tell yourself i'm
going to tell you it's not true
it would take some sacrifice and some
extra time and you're going to drop back
on this or you might have to let the
story that you need to buy a house right
now
you may need to let that one go for a
bit right oh yeah that one's gone
well okay so here's the second part of
that after you mine these things for
evidence the ones that are true
and here's i tell myself dude i
tried out for the gifted and talented
program when i was in third grade
i didn't get it they had me these
interviews and i even remember the names
of the teachers and i won't call them
out here because i don't even know if
they're living
and i don't want them to feel bad even
though they should right
not really i tried out for that i didn't
get it so here i am
three plus decades later i got two
doctorates i went to harvard for a
program
um i've got certificates coming up my i
could wallpaper a wall but
and did you know i still i'll be talking
to folks and one of my first things to
say is i'm not that i mean i'm not that
smart
and i'm not i won't be able to figure
that out
and that stuff's a story that's been
wired into me for 30 years
right it's not true it's dumb it's
every bit of evidence in the world is
contrary to that
and yet that story's still there so it's
one i gotta remind myself when i hear it
myself say it i gotta nope that's that
one's not true okay so
you're gonna mine these stories for
evidence and then here's the other thing
i want you to write down the things that
you can control and the ones you can't
do you have 850 000 which is what it
cost for a one bedroom
one bath in orange county no right you
don't have that
no so you can't control that one let
that one go
right okay any decision after that to
carry it around is a choice to walk a
little bit heavier we walk a little bit
slower
can you get back the last 10 years when
you have been working four jobs so that
your kids could eat
no no you can't get them back and so
every moment you spend in regret
every moment you spend a resentment is a
decision to not live
moving forward does that make sense
yeah and it's a hard annoying
frustrating everyday
decision to go through these things and
say i can't control that today i can't
control that today i can
go email schools and start now i can
make sure that i'm enrolled
in summer one session or it's already
through midway through the summer
so i can um enroll be enrolled in the
fall
and i'm gonna sit down with girls and
say hey here's what i'm doing and once
i'm done with this program you and i are
gonna there's disneyland on the other
end of this or there's europe on the
other end of this or whatever that looks
like
and by the way i'm not gonna live in
california move to kansas so i can buy a
whole city block for the same price as i
can buy a one bedroom apartment
right or i'm gonna move to texas or
nashville we'd love to have you right
um i'm gonna be gonna say i can't buy a
house in california what can i control
i can't control not living here maybe i
can control potentially this or
potentially that
and you begin to expand your scope of
what is
possible in the life of cara and i'm
telling you what when you start looking
at things you can control
and you start letting go the things you
can't control holy smokes man
you find yourself sprinting everywhere
because you're not carrying those bricks
anymore
now i simplified this this is hard i've
had a lot of counseling i've had a lot
of smart friends that happen to be
counselors that have helped me when
we're just having a drink or some chips
and queso
this isn't easy and it's not for the
faint of heart but my promise is if you
give yourself 30 60
90 120 days three four months of a daily
practice just like exercising just like
eating right just like get on a budget
of asking yourself what story am i
telling myself today
is it true or is it not and what can i
control about this
over time you begin your default setting
begins to shift and so when you have
that thought man
i'm not smart enough for this you go yes
i am and you head right back in
or i am a crappy husband no i'm not and
you head right back in and it happens so
fast so fast so fast it becomes
automated just like those negative
stories we tell ourselves are
automated to you can turn the dial kara
thank you so much for sharing with us
i'm so so grateful for you hey let's
take a quick break and we'll be right
back on the dr john dolone show
[Music]
hey what's up i want to take a quick
break to talk about the most important
question i'm asked almost every day
how do i find a counselor if you can't
find a counselor in your area
or you can't afford one i've got a
solution for you
i've partnered with a better help for
customized
online therapy video chat text chat
phone counseling it's a licensed
therapist whenever and wherever
you need them go to betterhelp.com
deloney for 10 off your first month it's
cheaper and it's available
all the time this is for you your family
and for everyone else that's coming your
way
take care of your mental health go to
betterhelp.com deloney today
all right let's go to kerry in charlotte
north carolina what's up carrie how we
doing
hi dr john i'm doing okay how are you
outstanding what's going on how can i
help
um so basically my parents are in their
late 60s
they do not have a will or any savings
or
any end-of-life plan set up and they're
not willing to talk about it
oh gosh
that's too worth why why um
so growing up not a lot was talked about
in our family including finances
um actually in 2018 my dad received a
huge inheritance which has been would
have been enough
for them to have a good bit of savings
um and by the grace of god my parents
bought a house that's fully paid for
my dad also bought a newer car beyond
that we don't know if they
have paid off any credit card debts or
not however
i know for certain that my dad donated
the rest of their inheritance money or i
guess his inheritance money he's the one
that received it
um to their church and when my siblings
and i
found this out we unanimously decided
that we were not paying for
any care that they may need in the
future because we don't feel that we
should be
responsible for their financial
carelessness
siblings and i are huge supporters of
you and dave ramsey so about a year ago
we attempted to talk to them about their
will and any end-of-life plans that they
may have
and we got shut down instantly now we
want to attempt to talk to them again
because we don't want to be blindsided
in the end but we recently discovered
that my dad has a borderline personality
disorder
and we aren't sure the best way to
approach this conversation because we
aren't sure which side of my dad we're
going to get when we do
yeah that's hard so here's the first
thing i don't care about the diagnosis
just throw that out okay um don't
don't dance around that um a 60 plus
70 year old person that either thinks
they're diagnosed with borderline or has
been
like man we're past that um
the reality is um and by the way you and
your brothers and sisters
you all got together i applaud your
unity way to go man
i know a lot of adult kids that are like
whatever what y'all decided to do
is kind of dumb and reality isn't going
to play out
you're not going to let your parents
just sit on the street and be like well
shouldn't have given it to church
you're going to drive off in your car
that's not how that will play out but i
do applaud you at least talking about
this
amongst your siblings okay um i know it
feels good to be like we'll show them
that same will show them attitude is the
same attitude your parents
taught you yeah which is the oh yeah
we're not talking about
right it's the same like and so what i
would tell you is as an adult how old
are you
i'm 27. yeah so you're an adult and
there's a really crummy moment when
kids suddenly find themselves parenting
their adult
parents which is what you're doing right
and this is super frustrating and super
annoying
i know a few folks in my life that will
not have this conversation
as a guy who has been around death for
so long i don't understand it
um and as a guy who's lost friends
who left their spouses with a lot with
life insurance with a will
i it doesn't make any sense to me at all
um
i've also learned over over the years
that talking about death
and talking about finances is such a
shame inducing scary
um fear inducing proposition that some
people don't have the emotional
or spiritual or mental tools to deal
with it
now they don't get a pass i don't care
if you have the tools you gotta deal
with it because it's going to deal with
you
right yes 100 of us don't get out of
this thing
right um the way my buddies john king i
love
he's one of my best friends on the
planet and i love the way he says it he
says the only reason to not have a will
is if you hate your wife and kids that's
it and so if you hate your wife and kids
keep plugging along without a will um if
you do
here's the reality you're if you do love
your wife and kids if you do love your
husband if you do love
america if you love your church whatever
yeah
i know and i know i'm preaching the
choir here you gotta get real you have
to you have to there's not it's not a
debate
if you have a dog where's your dog gonna
go where's your pet gonna go for credit
loud right
right so the only recommendation i have
for you is this
number one don't go to war over your
parents
okay at some point you're gonna poison
yourself hoping that they're gonna
they're gonna die right you are gonna
get yourself
so fired up and worked up and your
brothers and sisters every time you'll
get together
it's gonna be i can't believe how stupid
mom and dad are they're so dumb so this
and that
and you are going to just create a bed
of resentment and anger towards your
parents that's not going to do anybody
any good
it's not going to make a will
materialize right so you're going to be
deciding
to shorten your life over an issue you
can't control
right right and i know that's maddening
and i know it's frustrating
there is a moment when one of you and
it'd be awesome if it's you
um calls them or y'all all get together
and you say i know we all said we're not
gonna help them the reality is we're not
gonna let them starve to death on the
side of the road
and we they are going to have to sell
their house because that's going to be
the only equity they have it's going to
be the only money they have they're
going to move in with one of us or some
of us
or they're going to move into a
one-bedroom apartment and that money
that equity is gonna
pay down that apartment until they pass
away like those are the financial
realities that's the math problem
they're gonna be facing
um and just saying we're not gonna do
anything again it feels good but it's
not reality
and then here's the last ditch effort um
i'm gonna do this
i'm gonna give you a free will the same
will that i use
okay it's i use it with mama bear wills
we've got a ramsay's got a partnership
with them
um if you hang on the line i'm gonna
send you a code so that you can give
them a free will
okay right they may not use it they may
um
they may take the paper of the letter
you write it on and use it as two ply
that's their choice
right you can say i know uh we did the
best we could
and i want you and your brothers and
sisters i want one of you all to draft a
letter
um it'd be best if you hand wrote it but
you can type it up it's great
have everybody read it everybody sign
off on it and then this
may take a week or two i want you to
hand mail it to everybody if you don't
live in the same town
i want everyone to sign it and i want it
to be a love letter
not a demand letter okay okay
i want it to be a letter that says you
guys are growing up mom and dad y'all
raised us to think about the future
you raised us to think about um our
legacy
we're so grateful for the stuff y'all
did give us
now my gut tells me there's a lot of
crap
back there that you if you wanted to
write a letter to them
and let them have it it'd be a 40 or 50
page letter am i right
yeah yeah you're right yes growing up in
the house of somebody borderline
personality store that won't deal with
it
um the will is just the tip of the
iceberg right you've been dealing with
this crap forever okay
i know this leveler will be hard um your
goal is not to punish your parents you
can't do that
for them your goal is to say hey i want
you guys to have end of life care
one year my parents surprised me and my
brothers i mean my brother and sister
and i
they gave us for christmas long-term
care insurance
right they weren't wealthy growing up
they weren't um my parents didn't have
they didn't have a lot they worked their
butts off and they're incredible people
they didn't have a lot so they bought
long-term care insurance
and um it was a palpable relief
we all exhaled whoo it was pretty
awesome
um so all it says who knows that that
may happen
you can take this call and send it to
him if you think that will help
um maybe sometimes hearing from another
person but at the end of the day
going to war against your family is just
going to leave a pile of bodies and
nobody's going to win
and you're not going to get that will
and you're not going to get
that resolution that you want so you and
your brothers and sisters write them a
love letter
tell them hey y'all y'all got him a code
they don't have to tell them that this
is free unless they watch this show then
you're busted
um and we got you a will they can do it
on the computer together
tell them that one of y'all will fly out
with them and um
tell me you're willing to donate
everything they have to the church
whatever that you just want them to have
a plan okay right and you guys are gonna
have to get over this your dad
got an inheritance he did what he wanted
to with his money could that have been
else yes could it have helped you guys
out yes could have helped him out yes it
didn't
so let it go right right that bitterness
and resentment
just keeps you awake at night it doesn't
bring that money back
it goes back to those things you can't
control that and so i'm not gonna spend
one second of energy on things i can't
control
and when i feel myself trying to control
things that are outside of my scope
i'm either gonna call a friend i'm gonna
write it down and let it out man i'm
gonna let it go
and i'll say this again and i was a
smart aleck last time i'll say it
i'll i'll say it gent more gently er is
that a word
that is that a word medicine gently or i
don't think so i think
i just embarrassed myself um luckily
there's only 14 and a half listeners on
this
and i said half one of y'all is just
like doing something not even paying
attention so
you're a half a listener here's the deal
you have to have a will you got to have
a will
the mama bear wheels are not expensive
like they're less than 100 bucks
right you have to have a will if you're
a college grad and you just got out of
school
get a will right um if you are grown up
get a will
if you are a young um 800 years old get
a will
you have to nobody wants the government
telling them what to do in their when
they're alive
god help you you want them taking care
of your money and
equity and family when you're dead this
is your one shot
right to take care of the people that
you love i know talking about death is
hard
it is nobody wants to imagine life
without us here but the reality is 100
of us
don't get out of this thing alive and so
100 of us need to have a plan
i think the last i saw 70 or something
don't have a will
good folks i don't care if you don't
have anything to get a will
and more importantly one of the most
blessed conversations i've had in my
lifetime
my dad called met with me
said hey here's my plan here's where the
will is here's where all the stuff is
um here's where this is going to go so
this is going to go i want you to bring
your
you know this and that and that what an
awesome conversation to have
that's trust it's intimate it's
vulnerable it's my old man saying hey
i know i got a one-way ticket out of
this deal and me saying me too
and by the way i just got my life
insurance renewed and changed up
i sent my wife a copy obviously and i
sent a copy to my old man
just said just in case my wife is
sheila's grieving real hard
i want you to know where this is it's
just a common thing in our home and i
want to let everybody know if you're
scared to talk about it it just
brings your home peace and there is
there is no dragons that i know of
um and there is no correlation between
talking about death
writing up a will and then you actually
dying that's not how that works you
won't accelerate the process
it just lets you sleep a little bit
deeper
thank you so so much for that call
carrie you are awesome all right so um
you know what let's wrap up today's show
let's wrap it up and we'll catch this
next call
on the next one new song out dude i love
it
it's by one of the greatest poets of my
generation common
and it's not even on a record it's just
on a a single
that he released with pj and the song is
imagined and it goes like this
i've been dreaming of a paradise
somewhere a little paris-like where i
want to be
let's travel to the greener side a
lovely place inside my mind don't you
want to see
imagine layers in the game where we're
all players no more stargazing or police
car chase and imagine life
that bring us lauren hill type of
singers
but you just lost one even the righteous
schemers still at christ redeem us life
is greener on the side
the beauty that we see be coming from
inside imagine if you a god and she a
goddess
my people get free calming
so good man right here on the dr john
dolone show